Oh,
welcome to toxic Google today.
It is a great privilege to be able to
introduce Dr. Joseph Ashbacher of the
Europe European Space Agency
where he directs their
program on Earth observation.
He's going to speak to us about
the big picture from space,
from pixels to knowledge.
Um,
he has led from the very
beginning starting in 1998,
the Copernicus program,
which is a set of multiple satellite
missions that have become the most,
I would say, audacious, ambitious,
comprehensive set of earth
observation missions ever created,
going out with plan launches to 20,
30 systematically monitoring
the entire global set of land,
ocean and atmosphere.
And the goal is to derive
benefit for society,
humanitarian applications, climate
environment, crisis response. And uh,
I hope he will speak to
us about those things. Um,
it involves a huge amount
of data. I think, uh,
they're coordinating delivery of
data from upwards of 30 satellites,
delivering an excess of 10
petabytes of data each year. Um,
we have a cooperation going on now
where that data is coming off those
satellites and going into the Google
earth engine platform. By the way,
I should introduce myself.
I'm Rebecca Moore.
I lead the Google Earth Google earth
engine projects here at Google and it's
beautiful data that they're producing.
Uh, doctor Ashbacher is Austrian.
He has more than 35 years of professional
experience in Earth observation with a
technical background in the natural
sciences. And really the essence of,
of his leadership of Copernicus is to
shape a future of our planet that will
benefit all of us. So please join
me in welcoming Dr Osh Barker.
Okay, so good afternoon. Uh,
my name is Joseph Ashbacher and thank
you very much for the do introduce me.
I'm from the European Space Agency.
European Space Agency is well known all
over the world. You probably know NASA,
but Isa is the equivalent in your hopper
dop and space agency doing a lot of
activities in the various domains of
space. I'm very glad to be here today.
Thank you for inviting me because I really
would like to send to you some of the
data which we are producing and how this
data are being used for everyday life
and how they can really help make
our planet a better place. Uh,
let me start with one slide,
which is really showing space,
the final frontier. All of you
know, a spaceship enterprise.
You have all been very fanatically
watching it, including myself.
And this is really symbolizing that we
are at the edge of what can be done and
at the age of, of uh, what, uh,
we want to achieve as, as mankind,
but also to explore your domains not
only in outer space but also in terms of
knowledge, in terms of technology,
which we are doing with, uh,
as part of our daily work.
So what do you see here is
an image of our planet earth.
They can buy Rosetta and the Rosetta
may be known to you as the satellite,
which was flying to a faraway comment.
Our,
which was a releasing a
sound are called filet,
which was lending on the commit
and actually taking measurements.
The satellite was taking measurements
around the comet and the lender of the
comedy itself. 500 million
kilometers away from our earth.
Uh, this, uh, satellite
was working. However,
his image was taken much closer.
In fact,
the satellite had to fly around the earth
to make the slingshot movements to get
throughout the space. Uh, in this case,
a 630,000 kilometers where he
took an image or the satellite,
took an image backup our planet earth
just to show that we are having a very
unique vantage point on space
in order to look at our planet.
But in the European Space Agency,
we also working on other elements,
not only outer space and exploring new
planets, but also in different domains.
We actually one of the few based agencies
worldwide next to NASA and the very
few others who are covering all
the domains from orchids, uh,
to an education systems, the
telecommunication, human space,
flight and earth observation,
which is the domain I'm heading
at the European Space Agency. Uh,
what is Isa?
Isa Is composed of 22 member states or
countries in Europe at our members and
our funding our programs
and making decisions on how
the money's being spent, uh,
with uh, uh, in, in
dop, nurse space agency.
We also have cooperating states,
last Canada who are having agreements
with us on a longterm basis in order to
work on some of these space projects.
And the way we usually function
or organize our funding
is that we are proposing
our member states, uh, proposal, uh,
which may be attractive to them or not
because it is a voluntary contribution
they give to our programs.
It is not a subscription
by GNP or other means.
We are making a proposal to our member
states and if they like the activity we
are doing it put money into the pot
and they participate in the program.
This is a very unique way
of how we're doing it.
Meaning that we have to compete for
money, for ideas in order to really, uh,
and our outcomes which we are doing.
We also create inspiration for future
explorers. And this is of course, uh,
the nature of space.
It is that a,
it really inspires you and creates a,
your imagination and shows what
can be possible. In this case,
we are having a regularly open days
in our facility in [inaudible],
which is close to home. And, uh, we
inviting young kids, we show them movies.
The astronauts are coming. And as you
see, they can get very excited in the, uh,
seeing what, uh, what can be done
at what I'm doing in particular in my
directorate is building satellites and
methodologies,
how to monitor our planet.
And there we share a great vision
together with Google earth engine,
with also looking at the planet,
uh,
using its capacities to computing power.
You really make good use of information
in order to better understand how the
planet is being or,
or what happens on the planet,
how it can be better managed and really
derive information for decision makers,
but for the general public to make a
awareness of what the state of our planet
is.
So what do you see here on this graph
is the activities of the directorate of
Earth Observation on one child.
Uh,
these are the lines of satellites which
we are operating and developing at the
moment.
We have 28 satellites that are being
under development in our order book,
which is actually the largest
number ever, uh, which we have.
We are operating currently 12 satellites.
And all of these are rather substantial
satellites are where a lot of r and D is
being invested in order to have ideas,
measurements.
You see the three circles
here on the left hand side,
the green circle or the green orbit,
which underlines the science missions.
So really satellites which are
addressing questions of science.
And we are developing cutting edge
technology in order to address these
questions of science to answer some very
important points which are being raised
by the scientific community. Let's
take an example, a climate change.
We are,
scientists have asked us
to monitor closely what is
the extent of ice coverage,
not only the extent of ice coverage, but
the volume of ice on the polar regions.
And what is the change over time.
And we have developed a satellite
which is doing exactly that.
The Monitor regularly ice
coverage, uh, on a daily basis.
So come to orbit is the compound
Nico's orbit, which is um, um,
which are symbolizes those satellites,
which we call sentinels, uh,
that are monitoring the planet
through the [inaudible] program.
The [inaudible] program is a
newer program within the agency,
but the very substantive one,
uh,
because we are doing this
with the European Union,
we serve who has declared formally
Kapernick who as one of the two flagship
programs in Europe and
together European Commission,
European Union with the European
Commission and European Space Agency.
We are developing developing a suite
of satellites which are monitoring the
planet from various angles with various
instruments that would explain that a
bit more in detail in a minute.
And then the right hand side,
we have the pathology missions where
we are building together with Eumetsat,
which is the equivalent of Noah in
hub, uh, satellites for weather,
weather monitoring,
but observations both in geostationary
orbit and impala orbiting Orbitz in order
to really see the various
aspects of climate,
part of weather and climate parameters
knocking off a space and observation,
observing the earth.
This is a very good example of the very
first image. It's a typo satellite,
which is a US satellite,
which did Monte told the earth
in 1960 on the 1st of April.
Uh, the satellite was
taking this first elevation,
a picture from space.
You see the New York Times article,
which is referring to it as
really a new era in mythology,
which has started with this
launch of the satellite
a few years later.
Now we also having a satellites
observing earth for climate and weather
purposes.
Uh,
here are some examples that are
measuring and observing constantly,
uh, the state of, of cloud coverage.
But those other by the parameters to both
[inaudible] which is the geostationary
satellite and, uh, met doc,
which are the polar orbiting satellites
which are going on updating the wider
services with this type of information.
What do you see here is a
very good example of how
set the lights work in daily
life. In this case, you
see a superstorm Sandy, uh,
well known in the United States.
I was actually a storm that
costs quite a few tents off. Uh,
I showed this a first in the
Caribbean that you see at the bottom,
the start of a superstorm Sandy,
the storm.
Then when those votes and
at some point of time,
a mythological service is expected
that the strobe would, um, uh, towards,
uh,
to the east and therefore not cause a
danger for the Washington New York area.
Uh, however, as you see the
actual costs of the store,
which is on the right hand side,
showed that the superstorm sandy went
into the north eastern part of the
American continent and
Willie cost again damage.
I'd also Keisha this at this point of
time of interest is the image in the
middle which shows these values
are lines and different colors,
which are your forecasts off the,
uh,
off the path of the storm a few
days in advance. So in this case,
a 9.5 days in advance and you see that,
uh,
that was a wide variety of
where the story will end up.
A Benny few actually indicated that
he turns her again towards the West,
towards the continent and therefore
would cause with cause some damage.
And this of course was that
predicted, uh, quite well. Um, in,
uh,
addiction occula see satellites were
used and could 6.5 days in advance at the
storm actually would turn left and
right and therefore some measures,
but they can in order to improve that.
I should probably also say that in global
by the forecast or if you look outside
and you hear that the weather tomorrow
is Sunday or stormy satellites today are
the major data source
or forecast accuracy.
If you take all the measurements,
put together what we call in situ,
which is measurements on the ground in
the atmosphere with radio songs, uh,
by boats, by airplanes, uh,
those measurements which we
call in situ measurements.
I bought one third of
the forecast accuracy,
added two thirds come from
satellites of various nature.
I think this is a underlining and
highlighting how important Saturday have
become power daily life.
Yeah.
Another example of where satellites are
really useful is climate monitoring and
monitoring the state of our environment.
What you see here is the Paris conference,
which was adopting the Paris agreement,
uh,
which was a milestone in a
climate monitoring but, uh,
expressed by the political community
who have been committing to preserve the
planet.
And a,
this was a very important moment and
we have committed ourselves as European
space agency to use our satellites
in support of climate monitoring.
Some of these satellites are shown here.
The sentinel satellites,
the cofounder Cosentino satellites
are grouped in five or six different
families. Uh, they are, uh,
using different instruments on board,
on the radar to optical imagery,
the larger scale, a wider, uh,
scale,
uh,
measurements of oceans on the land
surface is a to atmospheric Trey's house
gases. So you see here on the
left hand side, a sentinel one a,
which is a center that provides and meter
resolution in the radar domain central
to have very uh,
much used because it has a,
an instrument on board
with 13 or channels,
a spectral channels that can measure
the earth state on a regular basis,
like a camera in the visible,
a domain of the electromagnetic spectrum,
but also in the name of it
and short wave infrared,
which gives information on the
state of agitation for example,
but also many other parameters sent in
a three s three installments and bought
again for large scale monitoring
of oceans and uh, and uh,
landmasses a betters parameters.
I will show a few examples in a minute
and sending a spawned five atmospheric
gases that are of course at the source
of global bombing and define the changing
climate.
Yeah.
So what we do with the satellites is
really measuring the earth's system,
different parameters that
are all interconnected, uh,
measure various elements of our,
of our planet.
Here we see the example of chlorophyll,
sea level height, sea surface temperature.
Knight was oxide, oxide,
carbon dioxide. So moisture,
but there are also many other parameters
which we are measuring on a regular
basis with uh,
with the satellites.
What I'm showing here is actually a
complicated graph and I'm not going to
explain all these lines,
but there are two messages I would like
you to take with you on looking at this.
Uh, at this graph here. The
first message is that, uh,
the different colors are showing
different families of sentinels,
meaning different
observation technologies,
which are really providing measurements
of all the parameters of the,
of the globe, uh, which are
the atmosphere, the oceans,
a polar regions, uh, uh,
which are uh, a system,
a system together.
And the various sensors which we have
put on the set on the sentinels are
observing that is out of the services.
The second message is it long continuous
lines in this case up to 2027,
but I could have this graph showing up
to 2040 and he would still see that these
measurements are taking place
over long periods of time.
And this is one of the most important
features of the compound Nicos Program
that we are committing ourselves.
We have satellites that provide
these measurements basically forever.
Meaning that after one generation is
coming to the end of its life and next
generation will be flown in space of
course with improved the sensors and
instruments and this will be followed
by another generation to really a
continuous measurement,
serious of observations,
which of course is crucial for
anyone to really passed in this data.
Take them up and use
them in the long term.
Sentinel one,
uh,
one of the sentinels which is measuring
various parameters shown here in an
artistic impression or it has a uh,
a way that instrument as the maintenance
torment or you see her also do solar
panels.
But the way that installment is working
in [inaudible] and taking images of the
earth day and night independent of weather
conditions because radar goes through
the atmosphere,
even if it's clouded,
even if it is a rainy even at night
and you can get data of this area.
I'm showing now a few examples of what
can be measured with these way down
images,
which are a bit unusual compared to
optical images of which you are probably
more used to.
This is a a way dot image showing or
different radar images showing. Uh,
the changes of our co-op's are of lights.
Cops are in,
uh, uh, the Vietnam area.
Uh, and what you see here,
the different colors is
different states of uh,
of the planting cycle which allow you to
read three for yield of including also
some,
some other information or you see here
are written on the slide that this was a,
um, a case where we had an El
Nino effect. That means some, uh,
changes in our global a global system.
And we got a loss of the rice yield
of about 16% between two years,
2015, 2016 based, uh, due
to the effects of El Nino,
which costs financial damage,
but also people who have been
suffering from this El Nino effect.
I or not having the food
security are required,
not the example of what
is radar data can do.
And this is quite unique is measuring
deformations of the surface itself.
You see here an image of Mexico City,
you see the red areas,
which are areas that have actually sank
in that have been reduced in terms of
surface height, uh, to, to uh, water, uh,
which was expected from
underground drinking water,
uh, water for other purposes.
And do you see here that uh,
in one month up to 2.5 centimeters,
one inch, uh, was actually the change of
height. This was done over three months.
Uh,
so in three months you had three inches
of a change or 7.5 centimeters of change
in the surface level, uh, in the city
of Mexico, almost not believable.
I didn't really happen that buildings
and all the structure above was thinking
in quite significantly
as an effect of this. I,
it's also just a pacing and you
can make sure this, I'm space,
our satellites fly in 800 kilometers
altitude and you can measure accuracies of
changes in the fractures in
the order of millimeters,
which is quite astonishing using a
technology called interferometry.
And the same technology has
been, uh, used recently.
You see here an example of a California
highway number one hour before and after
on the left side, before under the
right send after the landslide,
which was destroying the highway,
but also the sounding area.
It's happened on May 24th,
2017 and the analyses of the satellite
image shows in the right areas that this
is the area which was
actually thinking in.
And you can measure how
many centimeters are,
how many inches are these changes have
been made or you see here very clearly
that I, the extreme cases to have
been two meters, uh, off, uh,
changes in height.
You do this a landslide.
Okay.
But Isa is not only would using sentinel
satellites but also other satellites
which are walk yet for scientific use
and which are addressing some very key
questions of science.
What do you see here are those are what
we call earth explorers that have been
launched so far. You'll see ya. Gotcha.
Uh, which is on the left hand side,
s Moss,
a Kiowa south and small.
But that would show some of the examples
of this, of the use of this data.
Right now, coach here, uh,
which is so measuring did you eat of
the earth is actually having on board a
very highly high position radiometer,
which he is so emotionally engaged with
the changes or the cabinetry field of
the earth.
You see here the earth rotating,
you might assume earthy,
sir around a ball, uh,
is as a round shape. It does not.
It actually looks like a potato.
If you consider the uh, the
gravitational, uh, field of,
uh, of, of,
of the planet and the satellite has
actually provided the most accurate a guy
with the measurements or ever flown in
space. It has the ob did in the meanwhile,
I it was launched in 2009 and
it had a control to, again,
I'm the stop, uh, 2013, uh, which, uh, um,
by it measured actually
while it was descending a,
again with high accuracy
of these parameters.
You also see that the satellite is quite
unusual compared to others who may have
seen it looks almost like an airplane.
It has wings because it was flying at a
much lower altitude compared to others,
which was required to
make these measurements.
Yeah.
Now the example is a s a s mos stands
for soil moisture and ocean salinity,
uh, which is a satellite that is
measuring these two parameters.
So moisture over the land surfaces
and ocean salinity of ocean surfaces.
What'd you see here?
The uh,
you see software salinity
values over a period of time.
You see the months are on the right hand
bottom of animation and you see very
clearly there are some areas where
which are more salty and others are less
salty. The blue means a,
it is more freshwater,
so less lower salinity and the means
higher salinity areas which have a very
high rainfall for example in
the topic, uh, everywhere. Uh,
the water from the clouds are less halted
as compared to other areas which are,
for example,
further up north.
Yeah.
Another example of these measurements,
our measurements by our ice satellite,
which is measuring extent but also
volume of the ice coverage. Uh,
you see here the ice
volume and mass balance.
Our measurements as they are
taken by io site satellite. Yeah.
In the case of Greenland. And you'll see
the capability for loss of volume, uh,
off, uh, Greenland over a couple of years,
which are regularly updated with the
satellite. And I should also say that, uh,
for many years scientists have
actually been arguing if not fighting,
whether there's an increase or decrease
of the mass balance of ice in Greenland.
And this was a question which for extra
d quite a few years or I was disputed a
until NASA and esa half put together yes.
Science teams and all the satellite
observations which they have with that set
the lights but also other means on ground
and otherwise and have come, uh, hyper.
I've compared, uh, uh,
data sets and have clearly found out
that there is a net mass balance loss,
meaning there's a melting
which takes place. However,
in some of the areas there
is actually also an of mass,
especially in the central parts
of Queensland. For example,
in here in this, uh, diagram,
which is on a different, uh, uh,
satellite measurements
serious from central one.
I did also show us very clearly by
different measurements taken over time,
our way or the mass flows.
The ice flows actually take place.
You've seen in the middle,
uh,
the bluish areas which are indicating
that there's a slight increase of Moscow
of course towards the edges.
Uh,
the snow and the ice are melting and
the flowing towards the coastline.
Another mission which is actually
quite a challenge for us is um,
the uh, uh, a lidar, a
mission or called [inaudible],
which is using a huge,
a lighter instrument on board.
You see it in this big home or
the satellite of a laser or light.
A beam comes out in the ultraviolet and
we'll measure when it is launched in
about a half a year's time,
we'll measure wind speed,
wind direction in a three dimensional
field in cloud for the atmosphere.
Because the Lidar, the laser beam is
actually reflected on the molecules,
the particulates in the atmosphere
and the element is coming back to the
satellite.
And those elements coming back through
the velocity of the satellite allows you
to replete in three dimensions.
Actually,
this is a technology which
is not existing at all today.
Um, we had, uh,
some technical hurdles to overcome
because it is a completely new,
unique technology which we are
developing here as part of our R and d
activities.
At some point in time our engineers got
stuck and couldn't figure out some of
the issues that were, uh, stopping
some of the work we did called NASA,
uh, for help. Uh, NASA said, no,
no, we are not working on this.
This is too challenging,
but you figure it out.
Please tell us how we used
to have department because
it is something we would
like to do as well. So we
are, I'm knocking on wood,
we are looking forward to this
measurements. They will be really unique.
And I think something that our
user community, in this case,
meteorologists or the forecasting
services really need to have.
So global challenges on a changing planet.
Is this really something
that concerns have we won?
I'm not the only other space agencies,
but really every single
citizen on this globe.
We are working a lot in this domain.
Are you see here the Sdgs,
the sustainable development goals as
they have been approved by the UN system,
uh,
which I indicating a number of goals,
targets and indicators which are
important in order to preserve our planet.
Uh,
you see some blue ticks on the boxes.
These are the ones where space can
help providing critical measurements.
And we are doing this,
we're setting up a program that will
address many of these indicators, uh,
with the means of satellites
in order to, uh, really, uh,
understand the state of the planet
but also help improving its state.
One example is her urbanization.
Uh, you see here a Shanghai,
an image taken in 1975 in 1990 in 2000.
I need 2010. And you see how
happy lady city was evolving.
What do you see in red color? Here
is the hilltop area. So basically,
really the area which was a changing
over the last few days very rapidly.
And this is typically one
of the parameters that can
be measured from space.
Okay.
Another measurement we are taking
very important, very critical,
is a c level of ice. We all know, um,
newspapers on TV at the urban change is
costing among other things an increase
in temperature but also an increased.
So Sea level, sea level height, uh,
which has been recorded
here. Uh, Tim's a thousand,
since 1700, uh, over several hundred
years already based on measurements.
And uh, they called on the surface
and you'll see this window here,
which is the window when satellite started
taking very precise measurements of
sea level changes.
And then on the right hand side
you see the future projections,
future projections, meaning depending
on how much your global change,
we accept how much temperature increases
we have in which direction this curve
we go. And uh, you see, first of
all, the curves all point upwards,
which is scary. Uh, but also
the variation is quite high,
meaning that it depends a
lot on how mankind in total,
we'll behave over the next years.
Uh,
in order to decide what did we on
the upper curve, in the middle curve,
on the lower curve.
And of course we hope we are on the
lower curve because that would be the low
impact. But what you also see on
the right hand side is that, uh,
this is a curve of sea level rise,
which is going up very clearly measured
from space in this case with very
independent means.
We see here over the last 20 years
that the sea level on average,
most of icing about three
millimeters per year,
three millimeters may not sound a lot,
but if it's 10 years, 20 years, 100 years,
it is a very, uh, important amount
of sea level of eyes, of course,
leading to some areas that will be
flooded, small islands in the Pacific,
a disappearing some
cities on the coastline.
So being on the water
and not any believable.
And I described a difficult imagine
that this will actually happen,
but it is measured and it will
be happening. Uh, no doubt.
Same. Oh shown here against sea
level rise on the left hand side, uh,
sea surface temperature on the item side.
Uh, these are measurements which her,
which have been taken by satellites.
First of all,
do you see that the sea level is not only
changing on average across the globe,
but has a very strong local variations?
A does of course depend the weather.
Uh, on barriers, a ocean circulation
element are you see, for example,
very clearly the Gulf stream off
of I'm Florida water, your hub,
which has this red blue carbons,
which is having a very large
change of sea level, uh,
of sea level, uh, along along its
way. Awesome. A surface temperature,
sea surface temperature
on the right hand side.
Also changing accordingly depending
on weather, depending on atmosphere,
ocean circulation and
a number of parameters.
Other parameters we are measuring or
regularly with our satellites are the
extent of ice coverage.
In this case, the Arctic.
I this actually very interesting to see
how over the years and you see the scale
at the bottom, the extent,
the maximum extent of ice
cover, uh, is really changing.
It is known on this is not surprising
that different windows or different years,
hefty, different extents are some, a
book holds about Lesser Colton, uh,
the previous one.
But there's one clear trend and you see
it here that the further you go, uh,
forward in the scale,
the world's 2000, 2010,
the less ice coverage you have
in the polar regions. And, uh,
this leads already and even boy and
a future to some areas being icefree,
which used to be covered by ice, uh,
which has of course, huge impact for many,
many elements for climate parameters,
but also ship voting.
For example. Uh, you can for
example, here go from Europe,
Japan, you were saying the north
eastern acid, uh, meaning, uh, going,
uh,
north,
the Arctic area instead of all the way
around in Africa and all the way to Japan,
which of course is much longer
and therefore has a much
more expensive, I do dot.
That's also threatening environment in
the ecosystem in this areas because ships
are suddenly costing this area,
which did not cause the area before.
So all this is really showing how
sad, what satellites can measure, uh,
and how they can be used.
So what do we do in European Space Agency?
But this is happening everywhere.
Especially also he'd Google, uh, that, uh,
the space data are being
combined with all other assets.
So ICT, uh, s uh,
to other information which are
becoming a available in order to reduce
inflammation,
which is very relevant but also integrated
in into all levels of society and
therefore really being used for
everything on a daily scale.
You see here a bit the scale from uh,
a space 1.0 to 2.0 3.0 towards 4.0,
but you would also know as new space
where you combine these various elements.
What are these elements? What do you see
here? A new actors that suddenly came,
uh, came to life and, uh,
were introduced in the space domain which
did not exist before and have not been
there before.
One of them very prominently Google.
Google has been very active also in the
satellite to Maine with the Terra Bella.
But, uh, this have been uh, sold.
But with the Google Earth and Chin are,
um,
are checked or Paul Graham really would
using an information source which will
be of global value for everyone. Not
only decision makers, but everyone, uh,
to provide up to date, uh, satellite
based information for various purposes,
but also other players are coming,
uh, coming, uh, on the surface. Uh,
we have planet not far from here.
We have spire not far from here who are
building constellations of hundreds of
satellites, which we didn't, didn't
have until a very few years ago. Uh,
so that the landscape is really
changing very drastically in our domain.
And this affects us all, uh, public
organizations like European Space Agency,
but also private organizations which
are making good use of this data.
And we are determined to really interact
very closely for the benefit of, uh,
of, uh, the community.
So what are we doing as Isa do
respond to these global challenges?
We have organized actually or seminar,
um,
in May,
2017 in fact,
Scotty at European space agencies
eScreen facility near home in Italy,
and we've invited some of the leading
experts in this new space, two maids.
In those domains,
where are the biggest changes?
The fastest changes are happening. We
have invited two types of people. One,
uh, one group of people are CEOs or
leaders in building new constellations,
satellite constellations with tens or
hundreds of satellites that are coming up.
Another group of people who are working
with this data and converting them into
information using ICT technology.
And you see here the bottom hole on the
right hand side, a new El colleague,
former Google earth engine who
was one of our key speakers.
And uh,
him together with these colleagues,
they're really showing us how
fast these developments are going.
Uh,
what is happening in the world.
And I have to say that our community
has been really woken up by this
presentation. So it was actually
something that was a smaller revolution,
at least in Europe, uh, to see how
fast this development go and, uh,
what has to be done in order to remain,
to remain relevant and to interact
with these communities. Uh,
the event itself was a live podcast
or we had several tens of thousands of
viewers, uh, not only the people
sitting in the home, but, uh, uh,
people watching the movies
either life or afterwards.
And this created quite a quite some
interest which also showed to us that we
have to move and we have
to act in order to, uh,
to stay on top of it and to connect with
these communities. Uh, what we have done,
and this is something which
is more, um, specific to Esop,
but it goes way beyond the czar.
I have created something called the
field lab fee for the Greek letter fee or
like an English accent annunciation. We
call it fire lab, uh, which is uh, uh,
an open space concept where you invite
people with different expertise,
with different assets, bring
them together, work on a project,
and then bring this expertise or this
knowledge back home to their company,
to the institution in order to work on
specific problems. I'm inviting Google,
but also many other partners to
come with us. Spent six months,
one year or longer or shorter and identify
a project. Let me take an example.
Uh, today in, at least in, in Asia,
we are not yet using artificial
intelligence for the analysis of satellite
images.
But we know from other domains that this
is an area where huge progress is made.
Uh, Google is one of the
key players in this domain,
but there are quite a few are
very active, a very prominent, uh,
companies are working on this.
We know that this technology
will be very useful, uh,
for satellite images.
They cloud covers one example,
automatic detection of cloud cover,
but also some features
related to agriculture,
forestry to archeology.
Too many parameters which
you can see satellite images,
the huge amounts of data we are
producing require that uh, uh,
artificial intelligence would
really help in identity in,
in identifying some of these key features.
Of course it always needs to
human intelligence, but, uh,
because the volumes are so
huge, uh, it does also is,
it is also required that we need to apply.
This means,
and this is one example of where we
could say a Google with artificial
intelligence Isa with with its knowledge
or for of satellite data interpretation
and the access to its data
firsthand because we produce
a sending the data could
work extremely well together and develop
algorithms, methods in order to help,
uh,
developing methods to plan,
to save our planet or to preserve our
planet with information which we provide.
And that would hope that this is something
that would not only put a mirror to
us what happens in technology development,
but also to society and show them how
fast our planet is changing and what has
to be done in order to surf it,
which then leads to decisions that are
actually leading to a preservation of our
planet.
Another example,
which we are initiating now in terms of
addressing some of these issues is to
together with European Commission,
uh,
define a new satellite or
we call it sentinel seven,
which would measure carbon dioxide,
but at the scale where you can
really see where it comes from,
a in order to have a more accurate
understanding of the sources.
And therefore also what can be done to
reduce or minimize the sources or do you
see here as a,
an animation,
a simulation which does
not yet exist from space,
but it shows how such a satellite
constellation could work at.
You really can see where are the
sources of emissions, how do they,
uh,
transport through the atmosphere,
how did it mix up with other gasses and
what is the whole dynamics of greenhouse
gases and how it works.
And this of course,
it would be extremely relevant
information in the context of, uh,
of the Paris agreement in the
context of global climate change.
Actually in the context of really
seeing what happens to our planet.
And this is something
we would like to pursue.
A do a build up such a constellation,
a pub,
you have three satellites
at the beginning, uh,
in order to provide these measurements.
Uh, I dealt with the invasive,
what'd you see on the right hand side
is actually the measurement of carbon
dioxide.
A,
they have been made by a fiscal various
sources in this case from 2002 to 2016.
Uh, but the curve is a
very, as a very clear trend,
the very clear direction
it goes upwards. And, uh,
we need to contain this development,
but also information from space
has to be useful for everyone.
Or it has to go into devices which
you use every day. Mobile phones,
tablets a, for example,
equality, sunshine, adulation,
a smart farming values.
Users should use this data in an
integrated fashion of not only, uh,
using information from space,
but combining it with other data,
without the measurements and with models
in order to really make it a daily
asset, uh, daily. Uh, commodity, which
people use just as you are better,
better forecast or any other information
you get on your mobile phones,
you also supporting a APP camps,
hackathon's these type of things.
But I'm also showing this is image here
because [inaudible] plex is a here seen
from sentinel to which you've
known better where it is,
but it's somebody at the center of,
of this image.
But Google actually spreads
out or a much larger area.
And this is one example of,
uh,
of the satellite data showing the Salvia
here foresight or do we want to go,
what do we think is a way where, uh,
the use of satellites will end up?
And this is one example which shows
her what we call a control hall for
spaceship Earth. It brings us back
to the beginning of the talk, right?
We said that you earth
is a spaceship and uh,
we are working at the frontier of,
um,
of exploration and I think we should
establish a system that monitors the key
parameters up our planet, uh, in order
to understand first of all what happens,
but also to provide this awareness and
information with decision makers in order
to make, to do everything in order to
preserve our planet. And with this,
I want to thank you very much for
attention and I'm happy to answer any
questions you may have.
[inaudible]
are there any missions that you've not
planned yet that you think would have a
big impact or that you
wish in your own heart
that you could do? Yes, there
are a number of missions. They,
I met that many more missions
then, uh, then we have money.
But there is in fact what we do is
we are testing a new methods or new
technologies and that we are,
we are developing new mission concepts
or we are having an internal catalog of
some 50 of those missions are, which
really go across the whole of ancient,
some of them I've shown carbon dioxide
as one of the next challenges are,
which are we want to develop. But there
are also other missions that are using,
for example,
a hyperspectral channels as we call them,
which is not only 10 channels
are, are, uh, of, uh,
of an immature but maybe handle it.
So even several hundreds of of these
channels to have a very accurate, uh,
distinction of the electromagnetic
spectrum and understand,
understand extremely well
what happens on each year.
A place of the wavelength in order
to have a better distinction between
agricultural crops are used for mining,
different rock types and, and so on.
We've got a much better or knowledge
of the, uh, of, of, of the,
of the measurement on the surface.
But there are many applications,
are many ideas which we have, uh, in
order to, to measure various parameters.
I think one trend is, is clear, uh, uh,
people would like more and more
up to date information, uh,
of the state of the whole planet and
all the parameters of the planet.
And this is really an information
they want frequently. Uh,
we used to have satellite images once
every couple of weeks or maybe even months
depending on, on what the
data were. And I think, uh,
the population that really wants to see
a continuous evolution of what happens
almost every day or even shorter than
this within the day of certain parameters.
That's certainly a trend,
which is also very strong.
Uh, so you talked a little
bit about, or you alluded to,
companies like planet and spire that
are launching constellations of small
spacecraft. Uh, but the, um, uh,
the roadmap for the Copernicus
that you talked about, uh,
is still primarily oriented
around launching large
satellite civic traditional
story.
How do you see a miniaturization of a
space technology and privatization of
space technology changing how
organizations and like he said,
do your own business,
uh, in the decades ahead.
And this is an extremely good question
and that actually it's the main reason
why have you organized this event I was
mentioning before who realize and make
people realize what happens,
how fast these changes go.
And to question if I may,
uh, whether the current approach is
the one that goes for the next 10, 20,
or 30 years or we have to rethink
sometimes radically rethink our approach.
And this is really at the core of,
uh, of the debate we are having.
How does our ar,
how do a missions that are built
by public institutions like Isa,
uh, relate to these
constellations, uh, which are, uh,
have very different nature in terms of
satellites and information they provide.
My personal opinion is it
always need high quality,
highly calibrated reference missions,
which to private industry may not
want to engage because simply they are
inexpensive and very complicated,
a complex due to build.
And therefore the business case may not
be as well as so evident as you might
imagine. However, uh,
there are gaps to be filled and really
gaps meaning in the sense of of embolic
acquisitions,
acquisitions for example,
our sentinels are covering
the globe every five days. Uh,
we learned from planet that they need,
uh,
information every day or
even within the day. Uh,
so very frequent observations.
Therefore they are closing a time gap,
but they're also improving the resolution.
Uh,
our satellites are having 10 meters
solution with a very wide swath planet.
Satellites are going down at the moment,
the dose, three to four meters. But, uh,
the newer generations skysat below one
meter. And this is something which is a,
an a complimentary information. And, uh,
personally I think the combination of
these publicly funded reference missions
and privately funded or mission.
So constellations is extremely useful
and I think there's a lot of work to be
done in order to integrate those
data sets and use them together.
So you showed a slide with the
whole constellation of sensors,
the current and into the future.
And I think the concern is that
with that volume of data will be uh,
you know, drowning in data,
thirsty for knowledge.
Where do you see the
role of space agencies,
NASA East said Jaxa in bridging that gap.
And do you think that's a proper role
for these agencies or is that more of an
academic and or private sector activity?
Okay, then I said, well, um, aspects of
this question, which is actually a very,
a very relevant one. Uh, today we are
producing are extremely high volumes of,
of data.
Um,
actually the sentinel program is the
third largest user of data in the world to
express it in more common terms.
The amount of data we would use every
day with our sentinels is more than all
the photos, all the videos
uploaded on Facebook every day.
So it's huge amounts of data which we
are managing and which we are producing
and we need to help offer
our larger ICT companies,
Google and others to really
make good use of these data.
The data itself is of course fantastic
because they provide the baseline of the
observations.
But the real value is converting this
data and information and this is where a
company's coming,
commercial companies in particular,
we convert this or this
data into information.
And this for me would be one
of the biggest challenges, uh,
in the years to come to do,
to manage this massive amount of data.
It's not enough just to screen them.
You need a automatic methods,
artificial intelligence,
but also other methods in order
to really make good use of use.
I'm coming from Australia and maybe uh,
I take a small anecdote of mortality,
well known decision and he at some
point was looking at a piece of,
uh, of a compensation of one of
his competitor or fellow musicians.
And he was looking at it. He said, there
are too many notes. This is too many data.
Too many notes. It don't make sense.
They don't sound good. The trick is,
or the challenges to pick out the right
notes with them and the right place and
make a nice melody. And that's what he
did. And I think we have the same problem.
We have a lot of data,
not saying too many,
but a lot of data and picking out the
right pieces of information and putting
them into context is the challenge
of the next years to come there.
We need to work a lot altogether
and not on the east side.
This is a work which you're a space
agencies have to do with private industry
and with a lot of other partners.
My question is is on a low d technology
that's using the satellite requires
really deep knowledge like the saw they
talk about and hyperspectral and a lot
of this requires many years
of specialization but two
main use of the data more
meaningfully.
Do you think we need to preach the
Tenneco get between the experts and other
solvers in ICT? Is we're more comfortable
with maybe like machine learning,
artificial intelligence,
but might not have the knowledge to
exploit the data generated by these
satellites?
Yeah,
a very good point.
Um,
I think there are different types of
answers to your question because there is
some data which can easily be integrated
using, I would say computing power.
If you take a,
uh,
an imaging sensor and you
compare changes before and after,
you can easily see a difference between
one day and another, uh, simply because,
uh, forest area has been deforested or
a building has been built or something
happened and you can easily detected,
I would say almost automatically with
ICT technology and this is maybe the
simpler case,
but there will be a lot which you can
do with relatively simple means, uh,
in using this data, there's other, uh,
use of this data which requires
very high knowledge expertise.
I showed some of the examples before
our, what we call interferometry, uh,
that you can detect actually
changes in height at the surface.
And there you need really
the expertise of, uh,
of remote sensing or Earth observation
expert in order to interpret,
to calculate, interpret this data. So
it, it needs a combination of both.
Like always, if you really want
to maximize the use of these data,
you need the expertise.
In one side,
but also the means on the other side and
the means. In this case it's really ICT.
So I notice the focus on where all the
effort is monitoring planet has been
largely Europe and North America focused
both the state agencies and the private
sector.
Um,
how much do we need other parts of the
world to get engaged and how much does it
matter given that the
satellites are actually global?
That's to say a satellites
are global by nature.
So a satellite doesn't only stay over
America or what you hope over certain
country is circling down to earth and
therefore really take images of the whole
globe. So by nature, it's a global
issue which requires all departments.
Uh, I think, um,
I think one good example or where we
should really underlines that you need
everyone,
uh,
or the major players to work together a
tech CEO to carbon dioxide measurements,
which is not an isolated problem because,
so if you pollute here and
don't pollute their, uh,
it's no good because if the pollution
goes from here to there and therefore, uh,
the effect of the clean
country or clean area,
it's not working because the
pollution comes from [inaudible],
which transports it. So you need the, the,
the various countries or
regions to work together. Uh,
even if you have to say is we want
to be pioneers in measuring a CEO to,
for example,
to better understand the flux is in
the atmosphere and to see what are the
impacts on climate change.
It's not enough. You hope
you sir, small piece on the,
on the whole globe.
And it requires everyone.
And that's why we really want to engage
with all the major space nations,
with Jaxa, with Japanese, with
the Chinese, with America,
our European partners,
to create a global system because only
a global system is really something that
is sustainable and make sense?
Hmm. I think we were all very inspired
by the vision you articulated in the
commitment coming out of Europe,
the European Space Agency,
to monitoring the planet going out
decades for the benefit of all of us at a
time when it is critically important.
So my question for you is,
it's more personal when you're
turning these pixels to knowledge.
Some of that knowledge is rather
dark, that is discovered, melting,
polarize desertification, you
know, loss of air quality,
uh, all sorts of issues.
How do you maintain,
can you maintain optimism for yourself
and your 500 plus person team in the face
of,
of all this?
Um, indeed, it's toward
that. Sometimes you,
when you monitor closely the
state and evolution of our planet,
the news is no good news. Uh, because of
you see how it degrades, how it, uh, uh,
it is being destroyed. How the
pollution affects various elements,
how climate change increases temperature
increases, c level of ice increases.
I'm told them this is no good news
on the other side of our planet is so
beautiful.
And we once had an exhibition where
we put together some of our sentinel
satellite images mostly from Sentinel's
but not only and have put them on the
ball. Uh, and uh, the,
the title of this exhibition was
beauty and fragility of our planet.
And it is so to our planet is so
beautiful, especially seen from space,
but it's also fat child.
And I think this fragility is the one
that wants you to protect it because at
the end it is your living space. It is
our living space which we need to protect.
So, and to answer your question, yes,
there is a lot of dangerous or are,
which we all threats which we see
every day. However, stepping back,
the planet has so much beauty to offer,
and I think this is really giving you
the optimism you need in order to really
enjoy this, uh, looking at these images
every day. Thank you very much. Thank you.
[inaudible].